that Jake Paul
phenomenon is kind of crazy it's got
everybody calling them out and it's kind
of like the big Corner push you know
what I mean that's what I feel like is
happening with Jake Paul everyone's
wonderful and I don't see why they
wouldn't because that's a big money
fight
um
but
you can't take away like everyone's
saying those
are like rigged fights I think he's
hitting hard you know I mean I really I
really do think those are legitimate
shots and Strikes and he been practicing
boxing and
Jordan showing he's whipping their asses
so it's I I don't think that there's any
like uh Miss hype you know I think
there's there's he's got something going
on there would I like to fight him [ __ ]
of course how could I how could I say no
to [ __ ] millions of dollars so I
would uh definitely go out there and do
it but I'm not sitting over here saying
Jake you're [ __ ] YouTuber ain't what
the [ __ ] blah blah blah blah man you're
you're making money make the [ __ ]
money and you want to throw some money
my way I'm with you